my mum was um
the best way to describe it is
hysterical she just kept crying about
the pain that
the other person's
mum
would be feeling
i find that really difficult to
even try and think about
[Music]
i was out with my
friends on a night out
um it was one of my friends 18th
birthdays
and
we were just out all day drinking
just another weekend out really and then
as the night wears on and you get a bit
more drunk i got separated from my
friends
because as the clubs closed on that
night
i got some calls from my friends who i
got separated with who were in another
bar causing trouble
um which i didn't know
and they would ring me up and say oh
jacob is kicking off you need to come
come back us up
so me being the you know what 18 19 year
old i was back then
i only cared about my friends
and so i went running down to the scene
and
didn't ask
my friend you know what's going on why
are you why are you not getting into a
notification for why are you not causing
drama
or trying to escape the situation and
tell them to keep moving on
i sadly
took it upon myself to
get involved and um
through
i threw a punch at the guy that my mate
was arguing with and um
and he fell on the floor
what were you doing in the days after
that
uh the days after that
my friends came around the next day
knocked on the door
i answered
out the window
and um their response was
yes jacob you know your punch man
knocked him out one punch
like trying to like
praise me um for what i did
and i guess at the time i felt a little
bit of a
little bit of pride getting that
acknowledgement
from my friends
and then a couple more weeks passed and
i ended up my mom had saved up some
money to actually take us on holiday
um
we went to tenerife
and was like on a
it was like on all these like water
parks
and um was on his boats saw some whales
and stuff
and it was like the first time because
from when i went to secondary school
like 13
i'd almost like become ashamed of my mum
now i was like a young teenager
trying to impress all my mates and um
and i reconnected with her because i
didn't have that kind of
those people ringing me or
places to go stuff to do and
i just remember
feeling really guilty for the way that i
had
treated her up until that point because
she was the only one actually believed
that i had any
ability in terms of like
intelligence or
my capacity to kind of learn or just
achieve anything in life
and so i came back from that holiday
like i've got a new kind of perspective
um
[Music]
then a couple of days later after we
come back from that holiday the police
started reading me and all my friends
house and this was a month after that
punch
um
and then that's when it started to
become a reality that
someone had actually
passed away because of my
actions a month
earlier
do you remember when and where did you
first hear that
james the guy who you hit died
when i handed myself in at the police
station the police had called
my mum's landline number
and they said
don't worry um
nothing to worry about just following up
on an investigation can you come and
hand yourself in at the police station
i'd known
some of my friends would be arrested at
the time but wasn't 100 sure what for
anything and so yeah when i went and
handed myself into the police station
that's when they first um
yeah told me that they were arrested me
at the time they were arresting me on
suspicion
of
murder
how did it make you feel
a mixture of every
unpleasant emotion combined
shock
disbelief
self-pity
and i i guess at that time i also felt
unfortunate i felt like i was um
why why has this happened to me
um out of everybody that goes around for
adventures
why did mine
have to
have the impact that it did
yeah everything just kind of
flashed through my eyes really and
i didn't
in the end i just became numb
and just
blanked it all out
my mum was um
the best way to describe it is
hysterical
she just kept crying about
the pain that
the other person's
mum
would be feeling
and
i find that really difficult to um
even try and think about
because up until then i didn't really
know how to um
talk about emotions and know how to talk
about feelings
and even know how to
ask for help
um i just always
use kind of
running away
from my problems as the way of
resolving them or pretending that
they're not there
how much did you know about the guy
who had passed away
i think i
just knew the very basics that he was
28 and um
i think you're training to be a
paramedic
and
i think that was all i really knew
at that time
what was the court hearing like
the court hearing was um
it was packed
i didn't know who was in there
there was like random people from off
the street who had managed to get in
there who have just been nosy there was
some of my family in there
people who i didn't know journalists
and then obviously
i was told
that
you know the family of the
of the
person who passed away was also
in the room
so i think what i did is i put my head
down
looked at the floor
for the entire
process because i played
guilty early so there's like no trial or
anything i didn't try and
um
what they could say boss case or
you know try and get away with it
and and yes and then all of a sudden i
was looking down at the floor and the
prison guard next to me
pulled me
down
and uh
i didn't even know how long it got
i didn't even know that it was all over
and i was going to prisons
were you scared
yeah i was
i was scared and um
it just felt awful to be honest
i was sentenced to
i think it was 13 months
in the end was two and a half years
an early guilty plea gets you a third of
your sentence
i hadn't had any
previous
criminal convictions
my probation officer kind of wrote to
the church in the pre-sentence report
just saying that she felt the longer
that i was probably in prison
the more unhelpful it may have been
did you feel a lot of guilt
at the time i did feel a lot of guilt
but i didn't know what to do with it
because
how could i ever
how could i ever know
what
what the impact was
and i kind of think i was scared of
knowing
what the truth was like how that crime
had actually
impacted on the people involved
so what do you think helped you process
the guilt
because it's a common um
attitude
i guess that
even from
david and joan
um
i think
you know while i was in prison they were
appealing the sentence length
to
you know because they said you know
two and a half years doesn't
make up
for the loss of a life
but obviously
once they were told that they
couldn't
keep me in prison for longer they
explored
whatever options they had
and
and
one of those options was to actually
communicate with me
and speak to me
listening to what they were going to
tell me was going to be difficult
you know obviously they weren't going to
sugarcoat it they wanted me to know
exactly
what the impact was
um
and to hold me account
and i think
that was the start of me being able to
process my guilt which
i'm always gonna be
i'm always gonna be um
processing
and that's my
again some people would say that that's
my sentence really
out of the things that james's parents
told you what do you think made the most
impact on you
you know i was told by the parents that
james was the
type of person where
he'd want me to
make something
of my life and
amount to something positive
that helped me
try to believe in myself a little bit
more
because i knew i wouldn't be able to
achieve anything if i was just
stuck in the
guilt and shame of what i'd done
and that's when they asked me
you know what is it that you're gonna
actually do
with your life jacob because it's
it's okay saying
i didn't even want to say the word sorry
i said you know i feel like it'll be an
insult to say the word sorry i want to
prove to you through my actions that
actually i'm sorry and um
and then
you know that's when he says okay what
are you gonna do
so i said i'll give gcs he's another
shot at 21 years old and um
and smashed him
did his mom ever tell you that she
forgives you
um
yeah
how did that make you feel
very grateful
but i didn't ever want to um
expect forgiveness
and i understand that forgiveness isn't
something that is black and white
forgiveness
means different things to different
people
do you think if your mom was around she
would have been proud of where he got
yeah i think she would have been proud
she um
it was a it was a shame because she she
died a week before
i got my gcse results
and um
i remember getting those eight stars and
thinking oh
you know that was the one person i
wanted to
i was one person i wanted to
show
and say look mom you were right
but yeah i wish that i was a better son
i wish i helped round the house more
with my mum i wish i'd
tried better in school
but i was never going to let that be an
excuse to give up
and what is the future like for you
involved in
campaigns to raise awareness that a
single punch can kill
that
those men in particular
need to
talk more about our problems instead of
him letting letting them all
get bottled up and
end up coming out wrong
and causing more harm
i was putting together educational
resources
workshops
in schools in prisons
doing mentoring work
working with prison staff
around training as to how they can
get the best out of the men in prison
that they're working with men and women
and so i don't want any you know that's
probably been one of my you know mantras
for
trying to help as many people as i have
and for sharing my stories
and so yeah i just didn't ever want to
expect
forgiveness and i still don't forget
forgiveness and even if someone said
they forgive me today it's okay if they
don't forgive me tomorrow
um
the biggest
thing for me is my own
journey of forgiving myself
a car pulled up next to me the window
wound down i got chucked a package into
my car which was
yeah big and then i got chucked 400
pound in rolled up notes
to which point i'm sat in a card and
thinking
you know what i've just done